destiny is in Lansing Michigan welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show destiny you too
what's up right now and I'm kind of an
emotional wreck when it comes to my
money I have my $15,000 your income but
I'm in fourteen thousand dollars of debt
don't want um eight hundred eight
thousand is college thousand two hundred
fifty s unemployment a thousand is from
the IRS in two thousand eight hundred
with credit card debt mm-hmm okay
are you working forty hours I get three
hundred thirty dollars on each check so
I times that by four for each month and
then I times it by twelve and I only got
like fifteen thousand something is that
your but that's your take-home pay yes
yes and you actually are getting two
more checks than that so because there's
two months a year you get five checks
okay okay it's not like it's not like an
awful job I work at a beauty supply so I
work like 20 hours on Friday and
Saturday so ten hours Friday $10
Saturday's can I was Monday so when I
did try to apply to other jobs to it
bring up that income no one wants me
like for the little amount of time that
I'm available so that's kind of under
stress with a small amount of income
well or you could change jobs because
this job is not that great my mom said
that your income sucks yeah you're
basically working you're basically
working a minimum-wage job which is part
of your problem so yeah we got to work
on your career side because you're not
making any monies part of the problem I
mean we doubled your income all of a
sudden a lot this problem will go away
with it well I had a job actually at
intent I was through the temp agency on
and I was going to school for accounting
so I got jobs in accounting I found that
I was too incompetent to keep those
high-paying jobs and I'm honestly I've
gotten fired from both of them not
because
personality just what I couldn't do it
so I was making a lot more and I kind of
had that downgrade because I feel like
I'm not confident enough to work in a
Holopainen after those experiences well
I would disagree I think if you're
breathing you're competent to work in a
higher paying position than you're in
now now so you were in school and you're
not anymore
that was my second question I am trying
to go back and I want to pay out of
pocket so I can then get a better it's
like agree to get a better job and like
the fashion industry but I don't know if
I can afford to pay out of pocket
because when did you graduate when did
you graduate my school three years ago
two years ago 2015 I graduated was your
was your GPA in high school
3.7 so why could you not pass the
accounting classes it wasn't that I did
great in school I just got back from me
advisors actually it's just the fact
that working full time and going to
school full time just kind of bit me in
the butt honestly I'm very sensitive and
it kind of stressed me out so I started
I started working more and going through
life well you've got enough you're smart
enough to do the accounting if it's what
you want to do not anymore
why just because you couldn't do it you
because you didn't know what you were
doing before yeah hurts your feelings it
made me feel like I probably should go
towards something I'm working on
Siddhant in like fashion where I know
that I can do better okay well the
problem with that is is the fashion
career is a very difficult career to
land a decent paying job in very very
difficult it's it's it's like saying I
want to be an actor I want to I want to
be an artist it's the same thing that
that's a very subjective tough road
you're choosing there versus the
accounting I think you just stubbed your
toe I think I want to get you back on
the horse and get you riding again
hold on I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover to help
you with the money decisions and then
you need to make some career in life and
education decisions that you pay cash
for
[Music]